fudgie critic who writes and speaks
about emerging issues in the
intersection of technology culture and
society her work has appeared in the
Atlantic wired the Washington Post slate
and motherboard
she's an affiliate with the burcham
Klein Center for Internet and Society at
Harvard University and author of the tau
tau R tau tau tau Center for digital
journalism's report on the current state
of technology coverage and then to nomes
right to my left now is Chris couch
Chris couch is a science journalist who
I have had the absolute pleasure of
working with for several years now
she's also the coordinator for the
communications forum her own work
explores the intersections of Technology
and psychology
and her by Lions have appeared in Nova
next MIT Technology Review Fast Company
coexists Science Friday and Wired
magazine we have also for your
convenience put all of their Twitter
handles on the board act known Cohen at
SWAT SM watch and at couch CS and
without further ado I will turn it over
to Chris with further ado oh sorry about
that in addition to genomics book we
have a book that Jeff co-wrote with Joe
Ito the head of the MIT Media Lab on
sale here called whiplash which is also
a great book so both of those are
available immediately afterwards and
Noah obviously will be here to sign so
now without further ado all right thank
you
thank you guys all for being here we're
so excited about this panel I feel like
it addresses a lot of really important
issues I too would encourage you buy a
book it's a great book
so first of all I want to kick off this
panel by talking about a the central
argument of the book and correct me if
correct me if I'm wrong here
is really the the disruption and
individualism that's very endemic to
Silicon Valley has kind of in a lot of
ways and eroded humanity is that fair to
say I mean I was think about you the
question like the premise of this
get-together like have they lost our
humanity of course the glib answers did
they have it then the deeper question is
everyone every person has humanity so
what are we really talking about that's
happened and I think it I kind of
approach some of this from the computer
science aspect the book goes a lot of
the history of computer science that
thinking of people's machines and
machines as people is one of the crucial
you know mistakes or paths that were on
that I think is is scary so I think that
is kind of denying the humanity of your
fellow people when you think of them
so individualistically as little data
points and i think about like you know
in the introduction we talked about it's
kind of a well-known anecdote about you
know Google's first design director who
you know was asked to create a design
for Gmail when they were doing it and he
like he suggested a color and you know
he and they instead of using the color
he wanted that right they went and
tested you know they a be tested 41
different shades of blue and which one
the one that people use the most was one
they were going to choose and he
eventually resigned over these kind of
issues saying to be a design director at
least then at Google wasn't like an
oxymoron to have a human vision for what
they were doing when they were going to
test it and they don't apologize for
that because basically they say though
the color the shade of blue we picked is
the most popular one it's led to 200
million dollars in additional revenue
and so I think it's it's it's that in
fact that breakdown I've seen people as
data points and and I think they're not
apologetic about it I think it leads to
bad outcomes so that makes sense can you
speak a little bit to what those
outcomes are I mean for people that are
not familiar with with you know the
intricacies of Silicon Valley can you
tell me a little bit about how does that
play out well I guess what I was trying
to argue is that they are taking this
fringe philosophy or ideology called
libertarianism and making it seem very
normal and mainstream and so what do I
mean by Liberty
I mean you know resisting regulation the
idea that we should regulate taxis or or
hotels or you know you can think of all
the different companies that we should
regulate what children see on video of
not TV that we should regulate who can
pay for political ads I think should
they live in America should they just
declare what they are what they're doing
so that's that's one part of that
ideology that the this this distaste for
regulation and and distrust of
government which i think is really
poisonous to our society so that's one
part I think the extreme idea of free
speech is another one and I know all
these issues are complicated we'll talk
about whether I'm coming out too strong
I mean to me I wrote a piece that was in
The New Yorker calm this week about an
issue at Stanford and the bulletin board
of Stanford and whether you should even
back in the 80s whether they should be
any limits on free speech so there was a
joke group that told really very
literally racist and sexist jokes and
Stanford tried to limit that and there
was a such a fierce pushback from a
computer science department that kind of
people were talking about her now or
running Silicon Valley that it was it
was reversed and like to me you should
having limits on free speech is vital to
having a community that is cohesive and
so that's another dangerous aspect of
that libertarian ideology I think
they're doing all this and you know I
think some of it is done in good faith
but I think it's just having horrible
consequences so I wrote this book before
the 2016 election I was certainly
working on it thinking about it but I
think a lot of what happened there
efficient from that election bears out
of these points because you know the
fact there that these big companies like
Google Facebook and Twitter are so blase
about the idea that a foreign company if
our country could try to influence our
election or that there should be
disclosure of who's advertising whether
these powerful tools of targeting people
should be used by anybody to stir up
anger and resentment TV shows of this
this disconnect like they're not they're
not seeing themselves as custodians of
this powers they have but instead of
exploiting it for profit or for maybe
their kind of utopian visions of I think
like where Mark Zuckerberg is would a
dream of connecting the world that he
thinks supersedes a lot of other
concerns so that those are the
the effects I would just add one thing
as people will ask me when I've been
talking about the book you know what
property to do it because clearly it
wasn't the 2016 election and III kind of
think about how one thing it was serve a
turning point and you can look at me as
a hypocrite because it's about using
Gmail and I remember just thinking that
the idea that Gmail would have a
computer read your email which it used
to do in the past and in order to place
ads for it I'm you know my mom actually
you know passed away from cancer during
that time I remember thinking how I
never mentioned word cancer in an in an
email because I just didn't want like
hey if you thought of radiation
treatments or you know I just didn't
want that and that notion that like some
would be a custodian of my information
they're giving me for free and would
still feel like they had a right to sort
of try to commercialize it was I think
that kind of crystallizing moment for me
to if I think back on it
so so a lot of Sara's work deals with
Technology criticism not just of
Technology itself but also of the
culture surrounding it I'm wondering if
from your perspective you know do you
agree with the premise or how do you
feel about the premise I guess of the
culture of the technology world having
an impact on humanity and empathy and
civility I mean absolutely I agree with
with nomes kind of overall premise and I
think a lot of people have started to
unpack the kind of implications of the
way that technology is built but also
the kind of assumptions and ideologies
that are acted out and in the technology
itself and obviously looking at the
individuals who are leading these
companies and coming up with these
designs and looking at their assumptions
and their ideologies really do matter I
think the biggest thing for me is you
know I like to think about this in terms
of optimization I think most silicon
Silicon Valley leaders and companies are
designed around questions of
optimization whether it's the design
itself whether it's you know getting you
the information as fast as you can or
connecting people as efficiently as
possible or you know connecting you to
all of the world's material goods for
Amazon those are kind of questions of
efficiency and
optimizing for profit right those are
kind of taken for granted as the right
terms of optimization and I think trying
to unpack what those assumptions are is
really productive starting point to say
okay well what if spending more time on
Facebook wasn't the optimization model
what if it was a quality experience on
facebook what would that look like how
would that change the experience how
would that change the design of the
platform but also you know what would
that change about what Facebook's role
in our lives is so I that's kind of the
crux for a lot of the questions that I
continue to ask about technology and
society I think that the trick is you
know using the terminology of the
industry optimization and the way that
they're thinking about problems and
problem solving is actually a productive
way of like sharing language and trying
to get at you know we haven't
necessarily agreed to the terms of
optimization but they're coming from it
at a market perspective and that's the
kind of natural way for things to evolve
but we as a society we can start to
question whether those those are the
terms that we've agreed to or not one of
the things that I thought was really
well done in the book the book addresses
how many of the issues that we associate
with Silicon Valley now and with the
larger technology world issues privacy
issues of commercialization issues of
users being assessed in ways that they
may not agree to that at least some of
the companies that are major giants
currently Google being the one that
sticks out of my mind
really started with an ethos that was
entirely against all of those things can
you speak a little bit to I mean how did
we get here sure I want to just pick up
like about the I think the way Sarah put
all that was really spot-on and I was
reading her report that she wrote and I
think it's she you know kind of
classifies critics and and I could see
myself and I and I think that what she's
talking about is like over as practical
ways of trying to like get to a better
place and I think in this book I was
sort of looking at the history like I
care
skiing also trying to ask bigger picture
kind of questions like I think about the
efficiency argument it's not in the book
but I was thinking I was almost going to
make it the kind of beginning of the
book is this idea of like Gleaners and
the idea then the Bible there's this
kind of instruction that when you have a
feel that you should just give it one go
one pass in harvesting it you shouldn't
go back a second time and efficiently
get every little fruit and kernel you
miss because partly there's an ecosystem
of people who are traveling or poor
people who live off of the the gleaning
and that you know that is an a metaphor
where again you're saying you know what
the efficient thing would be like I have
a farm I need to get all the content out
of it that's what I do I'm a farmer or
you could say well you're part of a
society and actually the efficient thing
is let some kind of scraps be there for
other people because they efficiently
use it you know again it's like using
their language and thinking about the
picture there you know the the world are
trying to create and when I an editor
sent me recently a tweet where someone
pointed out that Mark Zuckerberg was
saying how he cared so much about this
election meddling or Russian meddling
the election that he was going to the
company was gonna spend all this money
to hire people that's why he mentioned
an investment call because was so
important they were prepared to lose
money over it and of course the natural
comment this person made was like well
you're basically saying you make money
from the current bad situation that's
how important is you're gonna flip on
that one and so that that's again these
efficiencies in the way they're set up
that are really troubling without what
you're asking about that history I was
trying to look back I didn't really know
these answers I was learning about how
did we get here that was definite the
question I was trying to ask and in the
end you'll see like kind of a thesis of
the book is that the computer science
half is accounts for some the hacker
kind of mentality accounts for some of
these extreme ideological ideas about
free speech and kind of lack of
diversity and hostility to outsiders and
then you know I kind of credit or blame
Stanford for a lot of the the kind of
profit seeking and so you know for me
the Stanford the Google case was a real
it like just in very enlightening is you
go back and read the original papers
that Sergey Brin and Larry Page wrote
when they were developing this which was
really an incredible invention like the
Google search engine or PageRank you
know I think everyone agrees that they
really had maybe they were they were
standing on the shoulders of others but
they real
created something that took this chaotic
thing called the early web and made it
you know coherent and it was incredible
and it's the reason why it like became
so popular it's an amazing adventure but
they really also explain as they were
described as amazing invention why it
needed to be advertising free and needed
to be in the in the actual academic
world that it needed to be a place where
it was transparent there shouldn't be
these black boxes now of course it's me
just come to accept the idea that the
Google algorithm and the Facebook
algorithm are these secret things that
no one should know what they're doing
and I'm sure Sarah can talk about this
and they're constantly tinkering with it
in this mysterious way I mean they were
arguing that's very bad for science it's
very bad for trusting the system because
if you don't have any you know scrutiny
of it and and so they wrote this paper
explaining all that and at least the way
I see the the story going is that
basically they they are serious
academics their parents were academics
they were getting PhDs off of this
incredible idea they had and then
basically it ended up using so much
bandwidth at Stanford that they were
told you have to start figuring how to
pay for this not to me it's a fair
question to say couldn't Stanford have
said this is a great invention we're
gonna pay for it of course we're gonna
pay for we pay for like a nuclear
reactor in our in our building you know
it's very important for our studying of
our society and science to do this but
instead they were told you'd better
figure out a way to do this and they
immediately were connected through a
Stanford network with an investor like
immediately before so early that they
actually they weren't incorporated so at
the story that's all these books is
about how a person who had been a
Stanford graduate wrote them a check for
Google Inc and they're like there is no
Google Inc he's like there will be take
the check you'll need it soon and like a
month later there was a Google Inc and
then they deposit that hundred thousand
dollar check and the rest is history so
I do feel like there was like a maybe
it's a little corny or something there's
like a corruption there you know a kiss
he called selling out whatever there's a
corruption narrative for them and for
Facebook as well where they really had
some idealism they kind of were in all
the power of computers and they weren't
necessarily trying to become you know
billionaires that wasn't what there was
making them tick I think in the book
you'll see there are other characters
like Peter Thiel and Jeff Bezos who were
bankers and that was really what they
were trying to do was to figure out a
way to make money from you now but these
I these idealistic hackers I feel were
kind of lead astray a bit that's my view
anyway Sarah even extensively about how
coverage of the technology world has
changed over time can you weigh in a
little bit about you know how has that
how is the media evolved as the tech
world has evolved sure so in the
research report I did for the Tao Center
for digital journalism at Columbia I
think one of the things I was trying to
look at was you know coverage from that
kind of early almost breathless
excitement about the Silicon Valley
moment the dot-com boom and all of that
kind of energy that went into covering
before you know the Amazon era and then
later in the Google and Facebook and and
others era and that kind of starting
from a very business oriented coverage
model or from a kind of tech bloggers
model and so that kind of breathless
coverage moving into something a little
bit more concerned with you know as the
technology starts to intersect with a
lot of things like politics and people
and society those kind of shifting that
the narrative about what matters about
technology and why this is changing our
lives and affecting our lives and I
think that that shift kind of happens at
a couple different points I think you
know 2007 or so the iPhone comes out and
like we all of a sudden have drap
dramatically changed our like day to day
relationship with a computer in our
pocket basically so I think but yet that
was still kind of in that gadget
excitement phase and then we have like a
2013 ish mint which is the Snowden
moment and I think that's kind of where
everyone comes to terms with the fact
that like technology has both good and
bad uses right that to me is this like
larger discourse moment where everyone
just excuse me specifically journalists
and publications are willing to
acknowledge that like yeah we need to
think about this also and hold power to
account and and so on
I think what's really interesting right
now and I think I wanted to touch on
this a little bit because right now
they're you know at this very moment
your book came out there's Franklin
Thor's book world-without-end which is a
little bit more about these companies
controlling our access to knowledge and
information there's also the four by
Scott Galloway which is a lot more about
the kind of monopolistic approach of
these companies so a little bit more on
the market side of things but you know
you also have Tim Wu writing about the
attention merchants
talking about you know these companies
monopoly over our our information and
our attention so I think it's an
interesting moment right now in part
because like all of these books were
being written before the crisis hit so
it's it's fascinating like the writing
has been on the wall for a long time
publishers seem to have acknowledged
this to think that there was like a
market for these books I like to think
of a lot of this and kind of meta like
where's the audience who does this who
is this for narrative that 2013 was a
sort of important moment I think about I
wrote a piece earlier than that about
this German politician young guy who who
petitioned to get all his data about all
the tracking that was done with with him
and it was like you know and it ran on
thing on the front pages of time so I
mean it was it was but it was again you
kind of point out in your in that paper
you wrote that the breakthrough is hard
so like it's writing an article saying
yeah isn't that weird they are keeping
all that data about you but until
something like Snowden really you know
gets attention for a lot of different
reasons it probably takes a lot of
people to to see it so I think that
probably what's a big favor yeah well we
were talking a little bit earlier about
the the problem of access right like who
for a journalist and I wouldn't be
curious to hear your take on this is you
know for a journalist to have access to
these companies they have to kind of
stay on their good side to to a degree
and that is especially true if you're
like the business tech journalist
covering the story so you know as more
kind of journalists from different beats
and different walks of life are you know
also coming to terms with technologies
of impact on society the narrative
starts to change right yeah
I think it's really I mean is where
you're pointing out is also the one
maybe the benefits from leaving that
kind of gadget phase is that that's less
important so I think there was a sense
in in 2007 like getting access to the
first gadget is usually important but
now we are you know we're kind of beyond
the gadget phase now the ramifications
become as important in a well-told story
explaining that is very vital I think
there you know I didn't seek out a lot
of access I knew that there wouldn't you
know wasn't really what they were is
shouldn't talking about it and I don't
know that a lot of them such such
there's an incredible site called the
Zuckerberg files where a professor at
the University of wisconsin-milwaukee
has just he kind of over privacy issues
saying that you know they know so much
about us has systematically found
everything that it's like marks like
works ever said and he has they if the
acne after like kind of login with him
but it has access to a usually its
videotape of it you know streaming of it
and also text of it everything he's ever
said since he's 19 and you know I read
like a lot of that I mean I think almost
all of it and and so likewise you know a
Marc Andreessen until he deleted all
this tweets he tweeted a hundred
thousand times so it's like you know
there was more than enough about him and
you know Peter Thiel's written two books
I mean one book he talks about a lot
more than the other one but there was an
early book he wrote that was really I
thought really revealing about what his
worldview and yeah so they all had a lot
of documentation so I felt like it
wasn't so vital to have an interview
with them when I did try the interviews
it was often very like meant to be very
stenographic you know I'm not not that
not that revealing so yeah I think that
there is a appreciation for the deeper
journalism the more critical journalism
you're talking about I think that's it's
great I think is we need but it has to
be supported by you know the the
institution's publications to be willing
to stick their neck out and you know put
that forward okay I think specifically
of the kind of Amazon workplace
environment example like you know the
reaction of from besos with for that
piece was just like what are you talking
about we're fine just to fill everybody
in the New York Times ran a pretty large
piece on the inner workings of
Amazon employees and it really spanned
from very low level all the way up to
hot high is lovely
yeah middle here middle managers but not
all the way to the top but they really
detailed the sort of breakneck work
conditions of that place and it ended up
getting lots and lots of attention yeah
and I felt like the responsive that
Bezos gave was really a classic
libertarian response and like baseless
obviously is the owner of the Washington
Post he's considered someone call him a
liberal Terry and I mean I think he
embodies a lot of what I'm saying in the
book and his response was very clear
that he said it can't be true because
these are people who could go to another
company and if they weren't if they
weren't being treated right they were
just wouldn't work here so therefore
they are being treated right and because
they do work here it's kind of the same
logical here a lot in Silicon Valley
that says there can't be you know gender
you know sexual discrimination because
there would be these arbitrage
opportunities there would be a company
would take all the great women
programmers and they would be the best
company and therefore it can't exist the
market would would correct for it so
it's that kind of and that is another
theme of the book it's definitely this
this detachment from reality the kind of
what was when asked about their
intentions or there's something very
seductive about the idea the internet
kind of can erase all the path so we
don't deal with history even like
current racism and sexism it's a new
world and so the to me was a really
interesting anecdote I don't know if
it's in the book but it was about github
and how this company get cut github had
a huge they're really proud of this this
carpet they had there was a big symbol
of github and it had meritocracy on it
and they were like we're so proud we
were we running meritocracy and then
women were walking and saying this is
really offensive that's like what's
offensive meritocracy it's to create the
best rule I mean the best rise up I mean
and they didn't understand that by
writing about having that as they're
like slogan they were in essence saying
what we have now is fair and if you
aren't represented here that's because
you didn't you didn't make it even cut
it so that I did that and I think the
head of github eventually took the
carpet away but was like such a
re-education for him because it they
really believe the world has been remade
it because it's a virgin you know a
digital world that none of the the
legacy problems that are obviously
current don't matter so it's a real yeah
well I wanted to do on that be
response because it so clearly
articulates this like complete disregard
for the physical world like they're in
Seattle like for them to get another
Silicon Valley job they would actually
have to uproot their families and lives
and everything else it's not just so
it's not as you know making it out to be
so yeah the question is whether it's on
purpose or not like if he's a smart
person and he's saying that is he really
not understand it or is he sorta you
know but that was always I always got
hung up on but when we talk about things
like biases and technology both in terms
of biases within the culture of
technology under representation of a
number of groups of people as well as
biases that are exhibited by the
products themselves whether that's
computer vision systems that have a
harder time detecting certain types skin
or there was an article fairly recently
on women having a hard time getting
prosthetics that fit because they're
largely designed by men I mean so many
of these problems just stem from you
have like a dominant group in power that
you have you know that you know Silicon
Valley is so very much dominated by by
white men first of all from your
perspectives do you see those types of
issues changing changing over time or
right now or we're talking about it
right I mean there are these there are
books are coming out there is a lot more
media coverage on these types of things
I mean is that landscape beginning to
shift or do stills do you still see it
as we have a really long way to go oh I
mean I would say that that it would
require a fort to change I mean it would
require the book is is fundamentally
saying that these these companies are
anti-democratic that they are against
democracy they're again how do we
correct in a society for to have
wheelchair access and fill in every
blank ideally we have a democracy where
people all you know it's not true but
ideally everyone gets to express their
opinion in and that is how you represent
people and
I was struck like Amy kovash are there
was a hearing that the Senate had about
that where they had the the top lawyers
the General Counsel's for Google
Facebook and Twitter there and she was
sort of explaining for them like very
patiently like we live in a
representative democracy so we really
it's really important that we control
our elections you understand that like
that's how we do it and and and so I
felt like that is like a real like
message they don't have that is
fundamentally how do you assure fairness
or you know we have a democracy if you
vote we people who are I remember
hearing it said that like that like the
Japanese internment maybe if there'd
been a japanese-american representative
you know the internment in America of
japanese-americans wouldn't happen it
you need to have some political way of
correcting these things I do think
fundamentally as long as they're gonna
argue that they can self-regulate and
that they are above the government it
won't change so I think the I'm like
kind of optimistic that there could be
some sort of a wave election that will
kind of present a new new path but I
don't think it can be done by themselves
I think it's it's the idea of self
regulation is is it won't work I don't
think they self regulation is like sixty
percent of the people that I interview
is just people who are talking about
well this is another problem that stems
from pure self regulation within the
technology world I mean the number of
issues that are endemic to that are just
just astronomical do you think it's
fairly it's hard for anyone to regulate
themselves I mean think about you know I
mean I if I were given free will to like
you know being charged everything I'm
sure I wouldn't be quite as fair you
need checks and that's like I mean I do
fundamentally believe in democracy I
think it's a little scary that you get
the sense like in Peter Thiel is a major
you know he I feel like one point of
this book would say that Peter Thiel is
not an outlier that it's that he is
often described as a sort of fringe
character but that maleeh expressing the
the the main thought there which is that
you know the democracy is bad that like
when democracy happens and you have not
smart people running the world and
that's not good and I think they really
but I really believe that I remember
like there was a person Max Levchin it
was who was the co-founder of PayPal
with Peter Thiel I mean he was sort of
saying he believes in regulation but he
doesn't like politicians and like you
know so it's like they kind of they just
think it's not efficient or I don't know
so I mean that's what I do think
gets down to our democracy though and it
is really important that's why I wrote
the book I mean sir are you've written
about how specifically within technology
criticisms that that world is also in
certain ways very reflective of
technology and that female voices voices
of minority writers have been overlooked
in a systemic way can you talk a little
bit about you know do you see that end
of it changing at all I absolutely do
see the changing which is part of why I
was looking at this kind of larger
ecosystem of people who are writing
about these things
I think certainly in the last couple of
years that it has drastically changed
which is all for the better I think that
also has put pressure on Silicon Valley
to change so at the very least
so speaking of like how now versus in
the future I think we've at least seen
the kind of oh yes we will work on
diversity for hiring we'll work on you
know thinking more about users interests
and needs whether or not that's actually
being effective is another question on
the kind of writing side of it I think
you know I I was really interested in
looking not just at a set of people who
are like covering technology but the
rest of the people who are also
contributing to a larger discourse about
the role of Technology and society and
so some of that has to do with looking
at a whole range of writers not just
technology journalist who's like beat is
technology but it's the people who think
of themselves as critics people who are
you know just writing an op-ed because
they their academic work has a direct
response to you know the current issue
on Russia for example so my interest was
in - in trying to articulate this larger
ecosystem of people who are contributing
and a lot of that has to do with you
know women writing blog posts about you
know terrible things either happening at
their workplace or critiquing a
technology that doesn't include you know
fitness tracking in the iPhone not
having a menstruation tracker you know
those kinds of pieces are
coming from a lot of different
directions from a lot of different
disciplinary backgrounds and existing in
a lot of different places and so
obviously that's not limited to
publications but I think what's what is
frustrating is that a majority of the
kind of traditional ways and places that
you would look for technology coverage
for a long time still were dominated by
you know your standard tech white dude
bro sorry no I like just hearing the
list of things you're you're mentioning
and even the thing I'm talk about github
that was a woman who was blogging that
in fact she had a bad encounter with
Marc Andreessen over it and that's of
why I kind of stumble on it sorry and
yeah there are things that no matter how
enlightened you are that it's not you're
not gonna be able to do that we were I
wonder if you like look at the example
of all the coverage of the harassment
and the media particularly and look at a
lot of that are women journalists who
are writing that and I mean is that like
a reason for hope imagine if there was
similar kind of kind of pushed going on
about that with the way the way Silicon
Valley works written by women in the
journalists sue yeah I mean I'm
certainly like especially in this
current like in the last two you know
two months moment I am hopeful I think
when you look back at like what Ellen
Powell went through with her I think it
was kleiner perkins explaining yeah so
Ellen Pao had a I guess she was in a VC
company kind of projects right and had a
sexual harassment issue and that kind of
just got shoved under the rug basically
but that again was you know probably two
years ago at this point she now has a
book out that is all about her you know
follow through on what to do about this
kind of systemic sexism and not having
an ability to have support and have
people take her seriously take her claim
seriously so we thought of that I can
remember the guys name exactly the
Google engineer yeah a lot of you look
at me and go like look up Google did
they fired this guy you know yeah James
Moore and like so you're sitting there
saying that there there are libertarians
but in fact they fired this libertarian
guy for his you know for really for his
like insidious ideas and what he put
there and I wonder how do you how do you
see that like because some ways it was
like a PR yeah don't know is the author
of the infamous ten page Google memo it
included a pretty large critique of
Google's internal culture and included
some information stating that women
might be naturally inclined to be
logically biologically less inclined to
for coding yeah than men so it went over
super well and and he ended up getting
fired and then he went on a fairly large
PR push um after that saying that you
know it was his like autism spectrum
that like led him to believe this was a
speech I never thinks I'm on Twitter
saying you know Charles Darwin couldn't
work at Google and I'm sitting there
thinking like you know there's so the
problem is that like Google is now a
company that isn't just doing
programming that would be bad enough the
computer lab being so non-diverse is bad
but this is actually affecting our
society so really even Charles Darwin
couldn't do other I mean there's so many
roles to be played at Google it's just
it's it's just a very weird way of
defining what what it means to be a a
tech worker anyway but I mean the
interesting thing on the kind of free
speech side of it was fascinating to me
because it was so much like I should be
able to say what I think and yes that's
true in a kind of public forum but this
is actually within the company and the
company basically saying like well yes
you have free speech but we can also
decide to fire you like that doesn't
preclude you from you know you don't fit
in our culture anymore
which i think is fascinating that
we have reached a point that Google can
say that that's not what their culture
is or what they don't what they don't
want their culture to be like I believe
that has anyway yeah sure right but yeah
it's still indicative of this you know
engineering mentality of just like very
transactional like very data-driven
assumption or you know backing of of an
idea and saying like this is the way the
world works and all of these kind of
more just interventions are not valuable
in his mind I think that there is also
as far as biases within tech culture
within tech products go there is a very
valid argument that as technology
increases as we become more reliant on
automation on algorithms the biases that
once you might once be able to hold
somebody responsible for say hiring only
men or hiring whoever that that if an
algorithm is doing it now you're losing
that person to hold somebody accountable
to can you would you guys mind talking a
little bit about the role that explain
ability and transparency might might
play with some of these issues sure yeah
I mean I think there's this great
interest in like okay well we'll let the
like HR algorithm system do the work and
like then we have to say that it's not
biased because well and it's not a human
deciding so haha but then of course you
know what are you optimizing for this
gets back to my main question which is
okay success if you're if you're
building this algorithm to say like what
a successful person at Google looks like
then you're already baking in a lot of
assumptions about their background their
history their schooling all of these
things that continue systemic you know
in Justices in the sense that you know
you don't have access or you don't have
the right background or you are just not
a white man who gets along and his you
know coding cohort so I I I mean I think
there are a lot of people talking about
this especially in the kind of AI ethics
and
shoutout to Brookman Klein Center and
MIT for some of their work on this on
kind of accountability of algorithms and
saying you know these are yes they are
objective and yes they are outsourcing
the decision-making process but looking
into what the terms are really does
matter and I think that's still a hard
conversation yeah I mean I was like
there was a footnote in a book that
sherry Turkle wrote that was guy I kind
of went back a lot and looked at AI the
one of the main and one of the chapters
is about a guy named John McCarthy was a
professor at MIT and then he moved to
Stanford and he's the one who came up
with the term AI he was an early
computer science you know pioneer but
also AI pioneer and so the whole I was
really just in the whole quest to create
a thinking being
again the idea thing of people's
machines machines is people thinking
that a brain itself is an entity that
could exist outside of a body just like
a lot of it really was a to me very odd
and revealing quests that these early
computer science pioneers had and so
sherry Turkle had so only a key scene in
the book is between the debate between
John McCarthy and this professor MIT me
Joseph Weizenbaum over whether a
computer could be a judge and they're
like they're really very Hank you know
they're very argued a lot all the time
they almost maybe they appeared in
debates a lot against each other and
McCarthy was like of course a computer
could be a judge a computer can do
anything as long as it's programmed
correctly it has all the information it
needs why couldn't it do anything and so
Weizenbaum who was a refugee from Nazi
Germany that was a really obscene that
was where he is I've seen idea that you
take something as human kneeling in the
loss to humanity is humane is being a
judge or being a therapist and thinking
that that could be performed my computer
was just a real disconnect with reality
so and sherry Turkle had this footnote
on that exact topic I think she knew
what and those wasn't new eyes him out
before he died and it was about how he
she interviewed minority students at MIT
like in the early 80s and they were very
encouraging of the idea of a judge being
a program of a computerized judge
because they thought you know we know
judges are biased and horrible and it's
compute
we'll be fair I think was that the era
when they really believed you know
computers could actually be these
separate entities and there would be
this like thinking being and then you
know cuts it ten years later and then
you know the review entirely switch
because I realized that basically it's
being given this garbage information
about how judges rule in reality what's
it going to learn how would it be
different than any better than what it's
learning from the kind of machine
learning arguments so all long way of
saying that like the these computers are
neither good or bad obviously the people
use them that's the problem what their
information they're given they're not
going to any better than our society out
why would they be again it's this
fiction that the computer or world is
separate from the real world it's like
it's a product of the world and if we
have a racist sexist society it's not
going to fix that problem how could it
and I think of one quote that wise a
mountain said which was that which was
kind of a carried over in the whole book
was the idea that a lot of the problems
that these people the computer
programmers I think that they're so
great at math and they should be solving
all those other problems he's like math
is easy at least for him it was but like
actually solving injustice or writing a
poem like that's hard so that it's that
fundamental it's connective thinking if
you're good at programming or math that
you actually should run our society
where we know how hard it is to fix our
society is the fundamental problem I'd
say do you feel that that technology has
any role to play in terms of correcting
correcting these issues then I you know
to contradict myself I think there was
this famous well there was this famous
court case in the eighties which was
arguing that that the death penalty
should be ruled
you know invalid because they showed
systemic bias so I'd say I think data
and showing systemic bias can be very
enlightening to the public so I think
you you know and the court and I'm not
using that and didn't basically said you
have to prove that there was racism in
each case you can't have some systemic
argument that our criminal justice
system is unfair I've proven it with
with data so we should fix it so I mean
I on the other hand I do think data
could really enlighten us about how how
unjust our society is and what we should
work on fixing but I don't think you
know a program is going to do that is
that make sense I know I mean yeah I
mean
this leads into kind of a bigger
question I had following up on the book
which is
you know I think you do an amazing job
of kind of articulating the ideology in
the history of where these concepts are
coming from and the kind of hacker
mentality butting up against the
entrepreneurial model but what I was
left wanting more of was like okay so so
what and also what do we do and I think
one of the so I kind of always go back
to Lawrence Lessig's four points of what
we do to change things this he wrote
this in code and code to data a long
time ago and so one of those things is
okay we can we can decide what the
technology is optimizing for we can
decide you know what terms were either
designing the algorithms for or kind of
what direction we're leading for and
that still goes back to the question of
you know is it optimization towards
efficiency or optimization towards
justice right but I think there's still
other parts that we could start to
unpack like okay if the libertarian
approach is a problem or the mentality
that like this has led to huge monopoly
systems right we can start talking about
you know markets seems to be one of the
so Lawrence Lessig's model has markets
code law and norms are the for kind of
ways that one could or the levers that
one could change society or change where
things are going
I'm like hesitant to say that market
seems to not be a real possibility here
like we have ended up in a monopoly
situation network effects basically mean
that the market leaver is kind of
impossible right like do we have an
alternative to Facebook do we have an
alternative to Google do we have an
alternative to Amazon right kind of yes
but not really at the scale that these
companies are operating at which is why
we kind of get back to the regulation
problem that's the law piece
I'm scared because that's certainly not
going to be a functional lever for the
next four years at least you know even
looking to the net neutrality moment
where you know we're sending all
neutrality limitations antitrust is
still not really set to address the way
that these tech companies are set up it
doesn't really apply to free surfaces
either right like the standard ways that
we look at antitrust which are like
competition pricing harm to the consumer
right these kind of don't work and so I
I think we have to think about other
ways to hold these companies accountable
but that has to evolve into some new
model that's not you know based on our
old our old Weaver's well norms I think
are something right here we're certainly
seeing you know if we're seeing what
happened with sexual harassment and the
public that's a norms kind of kicking in
in a way and I and I guess I am leery of
the idea of code ever being useful
because again it's like we not not not
knowing what you don't know so I mean
like a well-intentioned male programmer
I mean I think of administration you
know calendar it's like a and it isn't
even it's just like not yeah it's not it
won't be a viable solution so I do have
to you know so you say and certainly
it's you mentioned in your report to
that like the idea of what do we do now
is always a big you know a big question
and and you know I think they're
characters in your paper who talked
about how hey I'm putting out all the
problems give me credit for that I don't
have solutions that's you know not my
department as as they say and so but I
do I did try and and the arguments I
were making were that smaller local
things if the points are kind of making
that are that need to be fixed I was
thinking that like the power of
narrative that may be a mistake I made
in the book and maybe now I try to talk
about more is is to sort of embrace this
sort of individualism argument and the
because I do believe in individual is
and and and
and and and people you know
self-actualize they're getting the most
out of their lives and maybe the way to
think of this is the way the data is
that people should have a right to their
data and that that is like a way of
framing it that that something is like
gone off the rails that it was just
considered normal for these companies
collect everything about you and even
though they're giving you the services
in exchange it's not really done in a
very transparent way and it's just
fundamentally wrong I mean all I can
fall back are these like analogies that
like imagine if you walk into a store
and someone follows you and go oh oh did
you buy that that's interesting I'll go
tell I'll make a dossier about you and
like I mean it would be like unthinkable
why it would be a norm I know it may be
like people point out that like that um
you know may be an efficient thing is to
go to a store and you see that take a
penny add a penny and go take 55 cents
ago what can i buy with this I mean that
is a tiebreaker rule I don't know but
it's not our norm it's not how we behave
so I think partly maybe I'm hoping for a
norm norming away from these these
beliefs and and a belief that we as a
society if it's still possible to come
together and make better rules so that's
all I can fall back on and have certain
values like your data is yours and and
and partly I think liberal
libertarianism is one of the day because
even the way you frame with Snowden you
know I am i gut I feel like if if Google
and Facebook and other companies hadn't
collected so much data to start the
government would never have dreamed of
it it's like they they were the cuz they
are the custodians of all this material
and they abused that and that's like set
us on a very wrong path and we have to
get back from that path I certainly
wasn't there someone who the CIA
director if someone was saying out
Facebook has a better dossiers on people
than we ever could do because because it
wouldn't work a government like coming
there and saying tell us everything you
bought and what you like it just
wouldn't you know it would be we would
raise a raise your antenna so I think we
we need to try to get back our control
or society I it's that pretty open-ended
comment but but even even if that's and
I totally agree with that as a direction
I still wonder like how does that
actualize like does that mean we stop
using Facebook does that mean we don't
let Facebook do certain things does that
mean we demand certain features and and
protections of these companies does that
mean
have a cup-like collective action
movement about like you know [ __ ] the
default or some some kind of way of
getting into the the way to change it
right like yeah it's one thing to say
yes I need to have access to my data or
have ownership of my experience or you
know be able to voice my interests and
needs to determine the way that my news
feed is filtered right like we don't
even get to do to make a Facebook group
about this right now I think you're
pointing out things like Snowden I think
the election are gonna be galvanizing
moment so I was struck watching this
hearing that I watch to comment about
about the Senate Judiciary hearing that
there was a it was the the sharpest
questioner was this senator Republican
from Louisiana John Kennedy you asked
just pointed the best most pointed
questions about what's going on like
does it could Facebook you know give me
a list of having advertisers where
people are depressed and could I sell
them alcohol could I you know do you
know who's overweight and I sell them
diet pills or you he and I it's like it
should transcend you know petty partisan
politics I don't think it should
transcend like you know green versus not
greed or but I think that you know
middle America is definitely one that's
being hit hardest by all this is their
their their wealth is being taken and
being sent to the coasts you know by and
large so I think there is a chance for a
genuine movement I mean if there is this
you know belief in our political system
that there I do think that something
could change I think things are
galvanizing I'm hopeful I mean well even
in that case I think that's one of those
okay so if we're gonna define what our
norms are we at least have to have all
these examples and all these cases of
saying like yes this is a possible way
that this advertising platform could be
used and oh by the way we don't believe
that that's an appropriate use right I
think it has taken us a long long time
to get enough of those examples and
enough of those understandings of how
those systems work and what they're
capable of and how advertisers are using
them for example to even
Gentoo establish a threshold of what we
are defining as appropriate or not
appropriate and for the most part all of
that is kind of hidden yeah but is
hardening that like the senator I hadn't
thought of it I didn't articulate nearly
as well as that like he went right at
him and it was they were just kind of
hemming hauling is they were they really
look very concrete it was very it was
great I it was really impressive so I
you know I mean there is a sense that
yeah then maybe that is some more of a
burden and maybe that's what you're
saying that the book or the next thing I
have to do is to really be more concrete
and more galvanizing that way I want to
just tell the history there was really
like what Chris was saying was like I
wanted to just sort of say how did we
get here because I was genuinely like
baffled and I kind of came at this stuff
with a lot of optimism I mean Wikipedia
is like a real obsession of mine like I
wrote many many articles about it for
arms that really saw that as like an
incredible like anarchic you know some
of these little parts become this
incredible thing and I say I do a lot of
optimism about it I'm more was just
trying to answer that question how did
we get here more than like how can we
get it back but that is definitely the
next question I think we're gonna have
to open this up for questions in just a
minute I'm gonna ask one last question
and then if anybody in the audience
would like to ask questions please go to
one of these two microphones here we
would love to hear from you because we
are at MIT
I am obligated to ask you know what what
role does the University have for
students who are here who are designing
things who are making their own startups
you know what ethical considerations
should they be thinking of before moving
into the real world
Wow I mean because we're kind of saying
how the deck is so stacked you know and
not they want to say to young people I
guess I mean there is a when I was sort
of advocating for local you know there's
a certain 10 your own garden and like
try to create I would think there must
be a real thrill and like trying to
create a small project that can have
better values maybe not be driven by the
market
and seeing that kind of fruition and I
do think there's got to be a way to you
know not to sort of you they're
basically saying now because of them
Napoli we're live system we're living
with now that even new companies are
just only looking to be acquired and so
I would say that that you know I mean
Who am I to sit there and say don't like
seek your billions but are your millions
but like that would be the message to
try to nurture something that is smaller
I think there is like a real yearning
for it I mean somebody is seeking their
their billions which is weird that it
that's accurate here strikes me is very
strange what should I be thinking of
before on when they're on that path like
what questions do you feel that MIT
students should be asking when they're
building their groundbreaking
technologies I mean I think the hardest
question to always answer is you know
you have one intention for this
technology whatever it is that you're
building how to recognize the myriad
ways that the same technology could be
used that's always a really hard
question to answer until somebody has
discovered some other way to use it or
to monetize it or to apply it to you
know weapons and military industrial
complex right so I think that's probably
like learning how to see your own effort
from multiple angles of your own idea
yeah yeah by so many different people
right like that's the thing I think
that's missing from a lot of what
happens in Silicon Valley is like how
much user testing do they really do
where a user gets to tell them how they
feel they do so much a be testing but
does that ever tell you what my
intention was as a user my experience my
emotions all of these things where are
you basing right now there's using the
market as their as the only way to sort
of see what the intent you know and the
throw something out in this pivoting
right they call it like I'll give it
yeah there's so many assumptions in the
way that most of these technologies are
operating that and that's kind of by
design right like the data driven
approach is that we can look at what the
behavioral data is and
determine like what's gonna get you to
spend more time or what's gonna get you
to spend more money and that doesn't get
into anything about like what my actual
intentions are so yeah try talk to
actually talk to people yeah yeah
forging real connections instead of with
virtual ones would be a real way to
interrogate your idea because I think
even even you know Mark Zuckerberg scum
around the idea that there's more to
there has to be some real basis to these
relationships otherwise it doesn't not
good for us yeah one more thing which is
I I think so much of what we're talking
about is like the leadership role that
you know these individual especially in
the way that you have structured the
book is like the men who are in charge
who you know have these ideologies but
you know that filters into the culture
of these companies and it's actually I
think it's really imperative to think
about the more systemic contextual way
that this these ideas get played out and
you know how that is baked into what
you're you're you know engineering goals
are your your efficiency your like how
is your job
you know checked right like what's your
performance review having some control
over those questions seems to be another
way that we could like cut into you know
the the overall culture all right we are
gonna open this up to audience questions
now if you would like to ask please use
one of these microphones please be kind
and we're gonna switch off from one to
the other
we'll start at this one over here and
then next one is coming over to you
my name is Nina Linton I'm here from the
humanist chaplaincy at Harvard and the
humanist hub in Harvard Square so thank
you so much to radius and the folks for
bringing this important topic out in the
open I wanted to ask the question about
the Sarah you had mentioned that the the
technologies don't take people's
feelings into account and I wanted to
say from a an ethical perspective as I
experienced that I believe the use of
the emotions you know like an anger that
is a proxy for hooking into the dopamine
circuits and creating an addictive
experience which excuse me if my voice
is breaking I think is very unethical
and I wonder what your feelings would be
about how to answ how to bring these you
know bring this to awareness absolutely
that this you know this is like whiskey
and cigarettes and the rest of it right
yeah how do we regulate those kinds of
things that's a great question um
there's a couple things one is you know
there are already engineers and
designers who are recognizing that I
mean that's this again gets back to the
optimization question are you is it
really just to get you to keep thrilled
scrolling through and Auto refreshing
and you know infinite feed right Tristan
Harris is one of these engineers and
designers former Google person who is
working on the question of time
well-spent
so time well-spent I oh and that's
really driven by this kind of okay we're
engineers and designers like we can
design these systems in better ways on
the addiction side of things I really
love I think she used to be at MIT now
she's at NYU but Natasha dau fuels work
she has a book called addiction by
design and it's it's actually about slot
machines but is of course very relevant
to the design of any technological
interface and yeah she's very clearly
articulating this as like these systems
are designed to keep you in flow keep
you going
not necessarily to keep you winning and
that's kind of a really interesting look
at
specifically such a clear use of
addiction but people are have you know
naturally taken that and applied it to
these markets kind of broad consumer
interfaces hello my name is Elliott Owen
I was born raised in Bay Area Silicon
Valley come from all this stuff and yeah
there's a lot of complexity there
there's plenty of good things there's
plenty of bad things I think one thing
that really struck me was your argument
about inefficiency of if you have some
large corporation efficiently optimizing
to take over some market or some product
whatever it is and you're squeezing out
maybe the small people who live on the
crumbs I see also like a flipside I can
argue you know when you pay a medical
bill who's still advocating for an
efficiency when we have trillions of
dollars of waste in the healthcare
industry and it goes both ways there's
like a huge cost to inefficiency and
there's also a huge cost of the people
that you squeeze out there and so I'm
trying to think if if you had a tech
company go through and try to you know
completely redo healthcare and make it a
very efficient system you might be able
to save trillions of dollars boy what
happened all the people who you got
squeezed out from that system and I
think it's you can't really paint it in
black and white either way they're just
there's just trade-offs yeah I would
think in having universal healthcare is
is a much more important goal than
either one of those things yeah so in my
opinion so I mean I totally owe and of
course it's like there's a reason why
these companies are successful and
they're popular because if there was a
need for efficiency and to for hailing
cars or for shopping and so I guess
we're just sort of saying it needs to
have a higher goal I think boy Sarah's
like framing is really what is really
good that like you know the idea of if
your goal is just a maximize profit that
is not a good goal so that could explain
why you'd want